[Music]
this is star talk
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist we're going to do another
cosmic queries edition these are
becoming so
much the favorite of our listening and
viewing audience and today we're gonna
do fire and ice
i love it it's literary it's scientific
and we'll get into it in just a moment
first my co-host for this episode matt
kirschen man welcome back hey how's it
going matt i love it when comedians are
into science you've got your own podcast
called
probably science i think i get it that
is it
i'm two for two but i did it last time
and i got it in a row i'm i'm loving
this yeah the probably is in there for
good reason i i would say
don't undersell what you got going there
yeah i i like being described as a
comedian that's into science and not a
a failed math student who fell backwards
into comedy which is
is exactly actually what happened there
this is exactly what happened
so it means you do have math fluency
that's always good can't i did at one
point yeah
in life well always always good to have
you have you back and today fire and ice
um i'd love the literary reference that
that makes just you know
uh it's just it just makes you wonder
you know what's what's
uh is it good is it bad is it and we
have someone who's like an expert on the
fire and ice of the solar system and
that is natalie starkey natalie welcome
back
first star talk rodeo
no it's a little nice yeah it's
excellent excellent you're coming to us
from
uh from the uk
and let me get your official title your
public engagement officer at the open
university which is an institution just
outside of london and you're a science
communicator that's just a beautiful
thing because we need more of that can
we clone you you'll be the first in line
you know what there's loads of us
there's so many of us out there and it's
amazing you know and now i'm in this
field um yes
these are the practitioners there's so
many of us we can call it a field right
yeah exactly
a place to be you're a geologist and you
you specialized in volcanoes is that i
did yeah yeah back you know i feel that
it has decades ago now but i started out
as a geologist because i was fascinated
by volcanoes and i'm just wondering how
do you if if you're a geologist at all
how could you not be fascinated by
volcanoes because that's well exactly
that reshapes your planet right exactly
and i think the thing for me was that i
didn't even really know what geology was
when i was at school because you don't
really do it as a core subject um and
then i learned about volcanoes and was
fascinating i read this amazing book
called surviving galeras by this uh
volcanologist called stanley williams
and it was his story about how he'd gone
up this volcano and it had unexpectedly
erupted and he'd taken all these people
with him and ended up in these dire
circumstances and lots of people got
killed and injured and for some reason
that really inspired me to study
volcanoes and i was like well i don't
know why because i don't consider myself
a risk taker but
i just really was fascinated by them and
i then learned that actually i needed to
do geology to so the fact that volcanoes
can kill you earned a certain level of
respect
completely personally emotionally and
professionally and just to be clear matt
in case you didn't know a volcanologist
they're not it's not about spock or
anything star trek okay great so we'll
make that make that one clear
um
but am i right in thinking that you also
thought in your career that volcanoes on
earth are just a little bit too dull
well you know there's always that
because we know so much about them no
it's not it's not true i mean the thing
is with my book i've dedicated you know
almost half the book to the volcanoes on
earth because we know themselves why did
you mention that yet you have a book
called fire and ice i do oh
you talk about your book uh fire and ice
it's a great title and
um is it
you like as matt saying you were not
content with just volcanoes on earth no
no not at all because after i did my
geology degrees i moved into space
science so i was basically doing
chemistry on volcanic rocks to
understand how the earth formed that was
kind of my phd thesis and then i
discovered that actually you could do
the same chemistry on rocks from space
so that led me to analyzing pieces of
comets and asteroids brought back by
space missions um and so it kind of
broadened my horizons i've never really
thought about studying anything from
space before i never thought that was
really an option for me um but then
suddenly i'm combining all of these
expertise and so it can't kind of lead
on after my first book which was about
comets and asteroids and i wrote all
about those first and i was like hold on
i'm going to combine this all and write
about volcanoes and space because it
just seemed like the natural thing to do
and and let let the world know
if they didn't already
that you wrote the current space show at
the hayden planetarium called worlds
beyond earth so yeah
thanks for agreeing to do that and
and bring some of your expertise across
the pond as we say of the atlantic ocean
and it was we were delighted to
collaborate with you on that so thanks
for bringing that collective expertise
if you were just a geologist no we
wouldn't have had you yeah thank you
you need that space dimension that you
brought to the table and that was such a
fun show to write oh my goodness i
learned so much in the process as well
like having to combine you know that
kind of scientific expertise with you
know basically space artists people that
can you know image this stuff that we
write about we talk about so much and
using all that kind of real data from
nasa and e-submissions and and using it
to create this beautiful show it was
yeah it was a great experience yeah all
your words on the page are actually
happening visually on the dome yes yes
yeah and so so i'm curious about
something um is there a
um you know when we think of volcanoes
we think of hot things
and
so why is the word ice in your title
yeah good question okay so a lot of
people don't realize that actually most
of the volcanoes out in the soil system
particularly when we go past the
asteroid belt out to jupiter and beyond
most of the bodies out there are
actually ice volcanoes so these are
these are active places wait wait wait
wait
you're speaking like okay yeah most of
the volcanoes in the solar yeah yeah
let's go like do people even know we
have volcanoes
other places than earth oh i'm sure they
do
really i'm sure
most people i don't know i would i would
say maybe a fair proportion a large
proportion of the listeners of this show
would know it but i think if you polled
the average person on the street
i don't know if you would necessarily
think of a volcano as being
on other planets i don't know if you'd
even necessarily think of i i i maybe
i've spoken with so many flag earthers
the people think earth is flat they're
not thinking that they're volcanoes
elsewhere so i just have issues with
believing that this is why
even people who have you know who have
accepted broad acceptance of science but
maybe aren't as as
embedded in it i i would even say and
this is this is even something it's
obviously i know that the heat from
volcanoes and the mulch rock uh
isn't fire it per se but the idea of
something that looks like fire coming in
a vacuum in places that don't have air
that seems strange to me so all of this
okay so we have fire in vacuum and we
have ice in volcanoes so explain
yourself natalie yeah so i mean i used
fire you know to kind of just represent
the fieriness of volcanoes and it's
something i go into in the book a lot
but um we can also use it to represent
you know there are lots of fiery
volcanoes out in the solar system we we
had active worlds around us mars was
massively active kind of three billion
years ago venus our next door neighbor
is probably still active today it's
probably got volcanoes erupting today we
think but we just can't see them
happening but there's a lot of evidence
that it probably is happening why can't
we see them
well there's lots of issues with venus
it's not a very nice place basically
it's really hard to see it's um it's
covered in this is shroud of gas
basically of carbon dioxide which means
so its atmosphere is really really thick
and dense so it's really hard to see
through it you can't see through a
visible light you need like a radar to
see through it which we've done we've
sent spacecraft up to look through that
really dense atmosphere and we've looked
at the surface of venus and we can see
it's just covered in lava flows so
everything
that's on its surface is basically
basalt which is the same kind of stuff
that we find in places like hawaii and
iceland very very standard volcanic rock
that we see a lot on our own planets and
the whole of venus is about the same age
it looks like it's about 500 million
years old which sounds really old but
actually
in kind of the age of the solar system
that's not very old it's been active
quite recently and just to be clear you
called venus our neighbor but mars is
our neighbor too i mean yeah so the
thing about venus is that it's a similar
size yeah i mean it's it's just the
important thing is it's a similar size
to earth and it was made of the very
same ingredients as were all the
terrestrial planets all the ones within
the inner solar system and so it should
be
very similar to earth like we should
expect it to be very similar to our own
planet but it's not for some reason it's
turned into this hell hole it's you know
got a surface temperature of 450 degrees
celsius hot enough to melt lead it's got
horrible pressure on the surface so you
know the soviets sent spacecraft to land
there um decades ago and these
spacecraft lasted just a few hours on
the surface before just being crushed to
death so it's not a place we're going to
be sending humans anytime soon um but
it's a fascinating world because what we
want to do is understand why it's ended
up so different to earth like why hasn't
it got oceans on its surface um and
that's one of the big questions that
we're actually trying to look at now
we're sending some missions there nasa
are going to send two missions there in
the next decade easter are going to send
one mission i think the indians have
another mission going so the european
space agency correct yeah and so we
we're going to find so much about venus
now so it was mars i feel like mars has
had its day now like we've done it no we
haven't there's a lot still to find out
about mars but venus is going to be the
next planet we're really going to delve
into just a shout out to india who's
who's joining the
the fray there with sending uh probes to
planets so yeah they've done some
amazing work there you know their space
agency is doing great so there's going
to be so much information coming back
it's really exciting it's just amazing
now where does ice fit into this oh yeah
i i went off on the tangent as i said
the ice part is going to represent all
those volcanoes that are past the
asteroid belt so we've got basically a
lot of moons around these giant planets
out in the outer solar system so we take
jupiter saturn uranus and neptune
they've all got lots of moons around
them like jupiter has about 79 moons
that we've found so far so it's just
loads of them you know we just we've
just got one and i'm like okay jupiter's
kind of greedy but it is a big planet
many of those moons kind of lame excuses
for moons no not at all i would say ours
is a bit lame now now i've learned about
all these other ones like
i meant just in terms of how tiny they
are no no no no not at all so our
you know some of the moons out there are
actually as big as mercury no i'm under
79 moons of jupiter some of them some of
them are not you know potentially so
interesting but if we take the galilean
moons we've got you know io we've got
ganymede europa these are all really
cool places io is is hot it's very much
like earth was kind of four billion
years ago it's for the most volcanically
active object in the solar system so it
erupts these plumes of rock almost
continuously off its surface in fact
every space mission that's gone by has
seen it erupting um but then all the
other moons there are kind of icy moons
so they've got these rocky interiors but
then they're either ocean worlds with an
ice cap on the outside or they're just
made of ice um and these are the really
interesting ones because in order to
have sort of an ocean underneath the ice
we know that they must still be warm
inside that rocky interior must still be
warm somehow it must be warm enough to
heat the ice to turn it into a liquid um
and so this instantly tells us that
these worlds are active and interesting
places to go and sure enough the more
we've looked the more we've discovered
that they have volcanoes on the surface
so they have plumes of material shooting
out from their oceans which shows us
that there's a lot going on beneath the
surface
so we can call those ice volcanoes i
guess or something right yeah so they're
all like ice volcanoes or cryo volcanoes
cryo being the cold parts so uh and
there's loads of them they're everywhere
they're everywhere we look so actually
it's almost like the ice volcanoes are
more common than the kind of the hot
ones that we see in the inner solar
system so your book is like long overdue
somebody should have been talking about
this long ago it should be like in all
the classes
well this is the thing it's it's quite
it's always quite recent that we've
really learned about all of these places
in fact you know the voyager missions
went out kind of 1970s and 80s and
before that we had no idea that these
places were active in fact we didn't
even know some of these moons existed
and as we got out there and we started
to photograph them and we were then very
surprised by the results so i was at
school during that time and of course
that was you know cutting-edge research
happening at the time that's not going
to be in the school curriculum so it
takes a while for that to kind of filter
down and but what we then discovered was
actually some of the data that voyager
got and we didn't see some of this stuff
at the time so it needed kind of
reprocessing so we go back with other
missions later and we spy this plume
shooting off the surface of enceladus or
somewhere then we can go back to earlier
data that is still sitting in the
archives and reprocess it and go oh look
we would have seen it there if we'd
looked more carefully we now have loads
of evidence that these things have been
active for decades um so really it just
takes incremental steps of missions
going out and discovering this stuff but
we've barely been out to the outer solar
system many times like we've been there
just you know a handful of missions so
there's still a lot this is an
interesting fact that if you do flybys
you just have these snapshots of a
moment in time yeah where you then have
to generalize what the thing is doing
all the rest of the time which could be
very hard like if i'm trying to think of
an alien flew by earth and i just
happened to be in the bathroom when that
happened they would generalize my whole
life well he lives in the bay
like you need at least another data
point
to capture that matt did uh did you
collect questions for us for today we've
got a bunch of questions from uh patreon
patrons who've messaged in actually i
just have to announce you you also have
a brit accent here
i do yeah
when i go back to london now i get
called the american because
my accent has imperceptibly changed to
american ears but as far as brits are
concerned now i might as well be from
texas
i can definitely hear a twang in there i
think you're somewhere in the middle of
the atlantic at the minute oh yeah it
hasn't fully crossed one way or the
other
all right what question gabe what do you
have for us well so i i think you you've
sort of half answered this already but i
i just want to pin down this question
from adam smith just to kick things off
because he says
is there such a thing as cold volcanoes
or ice volcanoes i imagine ice being
spat out like in the way mr freeze did
in the 1997 batman and robin film
character played by arnold
schwarzenegger or is this illogical due
to pressure causing heat i mostly wanted
to ask that question because of how
detailed he went in with the specificity
of the thing
he needed to know exactly which
iteration of batman and mr freeze he was
talking about yeah because you don't
want to get confused with some other
rendering
and play by a different character
actually we got to take a quick break
but when we come back wouldn't get
natalie to explain to us
how
an ice volcano actually works because
that's
that's a mystery to all of us here when
we come back on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
fire and ice
i've got natalie starkey who has a book
with that title geologist
turned uh
turned astro person right but what she
worked on became interesting when she
stepped out into space that happens
whatever you're doing on earth if you
add space to it it's more interesting
that's that's my bias i bet that's your
bias too now natalie isn't it yeah
you definitely all right matt you left
off with a question about arnold
schwarzenegger was it i do yes as the uh
as today's space co-host uh i'd like to
ask this question from uh yes this is
from adam smith who is one of the many
patreon patrons whose questions were
answering today
and uh there's a lot of batman specific
parts to the question but the main part
is
does
what what is the deal with ice volcanoes
and
does ice get spat out from these
volcanoes or is this illogical due to
pressure causing heat yeah yeah because
pressure whether or not pressure even
causes heat pressure wouldn't have to
cause heat it just has to be pressure
right i mean if something gets spewed
out of a volcano it it doesn't have to
be heat that does it is that right so no
yeah this is kind of a tricky one to
answer it's a great question for that
reason um but basically there's lots of
different ways that volcanoes can erupt
and i think what we need to get away
from is thinking having to think of a
volcano is a conical shaped mountain
like we see on earth because actually
when we go out into space we don't need
that we don't need a conical shaped
mountain to have a volcano because we
have to just define better what a
volcano is we're sort of skewed towards
what we have on earth because that's
where we first studied volcanoes so we
think they have to look a certain way
but we go out into the solar system and
we look at these other objects around us
and we start going okay well this is a
volcano this is material coming out from
the inside of this world and it's
spewing out onto the surface and that's
happening because there's heat with
inside that world and it's producing
a molten material or gas and it's
forcing it ejecting it out and that is
basically a volcanic type of activity so
we see this enceladus basically what's
happening there is that there is heat
generated within that world because as
enceladus goes about its orbit around
saturn it's sort of pulled and pushed on
the inside by the gravity of saturn so
it kind of gets a bit closer a bit
further away from saturn and so it's
called tidal heating it's very much like
we get with the earth and the moon and
that we kind of squash slightly and our
tides move
but within um enceladus for example
actually the insides of it are squash so
it's rock creates friction and heat and
that then heats the ocean above it and
eventually kind of opens cracks in the
surface that then allow material to
escape so you'll see it as a plume that
material ends up raining back down onto
the surface of enceladus and you know
resurfacing that body but not only that
but these are kind of what we're
actually spewing out is basically gases
ice particles little pieces of silica
grains which come from the very bottom
of that ocean and some of these ice
particles actually start to make um
saturn's e-ring so they get sent so high
up into space that that is the reason we
have saturn's earring within which
enceladus kind of orbits so
that's yeah a much longer answer and
that's only one way that we can kind of
make volcanoes on these bodies but yeah
in a way i kind of think that's like the
mr freeze character that we're spewing
out ice particles into space and that's
by sampling those which we did with the
cassini mission um we know where they're
coming from because they're salty we
know they're from a salty liquid ocean
below the crust um so that's really cool
right so so if there were fish there
could fish be spewed out too you're
gonna fish in the e-ring yeah exactly i
love this now that we need to go back
because
i was just kidding you're telling me
it's like
this could be shot
anything could so whatever's down there
is going to come out in these plumes now
the thing is when cassini went it didn't
know it needed to measure this stuff
that was coming out in the plumes
because we didn't know they were
happening so this is one of these things
with space missions we then learn stuff
and we go ah we need another mission we
need to go back and specifically look at
these plumes and the material that's in
them what we do know is that there's all
the right materials for organic content
being there so we know that there's
chemical reactions happening within that
ocean that can create organic molecules
now it's a step then to say okay we need
to find a life but there's every chance
that it could be down there it's got all
the right conditions for life to form
okay not human like life but other kind
of life that we might find at the bottom
of earth stations for example which is
going to be a very similar environment
so yeah every chance we need to get down
there and have a look basically
so it must be hard enough for a fish
in an earth ocean to be
caught
you know with a line and then thrown
back and have to explain to other fish
what they saw
right that's gotta be hard enough and
now we're gonna have a fish spewed into
orbit around saturn
when they were happily swimming beneath
them yeah just be sort of orbiting
around the fish on the
on the ground just like get that get
back get back get back here
crazy stop messing around
just all right so there you go all right
so matt what more do you have that's a
great that was a great question uh my
biggest takeaway from your answer there
is that uh the batman robin film was
scientifically accurate
so that's nice to know i i like i always
love it when a question comes from the
children of listeners
okay i like the idea that there's some
young kids who are interested in this
stuff so this is from wes denham's
seven-year-old son silas who asks what
is the process that magma goes through
to be able to rise to the surface before
it explodes oh my goodness what what a
question
that's amazing i always love the ones
from the kids because they they're
always the hardest to answer you're like
oh it's you know everyone's like oh it'd
be a really simple question like no
that's not simple to answer well just to
be clear that what you call magma
we call lava is that right
so yeah basically magma is uh before
it's erupted so below the surface if we
have molten rock it will be called magma
as soon as it goes above the surface and
it's an erupted out of a volcano it
becomes a lava now even though it's the
same stuff we just have a different
world exactly the same stuff and then
after it hardens then you call it basalt
well it yeah it will be a basaltic lava
and then when it hardens it's a yeah
it's a assaulted rock or a castle yeah
so you geologists damn dark i know you
just like to make life complicated okay
okay so
okay so now let's and and who's who
asked this question again matt this is
young silas seven-year-old silas she's
seven oh my gosh yeah okay i'll point
out something else though because when
we go to the outer solar system and go
to these icy worlds remember our view of
volcanoes are skewed towards what we
have on earth so we think volcanoes need
to be rocky and then we go out there and
go oh no they don't they can be icy so
basically when we talk about magma or
lava on for example pluto let's take
plutix that's a great example um it's
not rocky the stuff that pluto is made
of it's all ice so when we talk about
pluto's magma it's basically just the
molten version of whatever it's made of
it's bedrock is water ice and ammonia
and methane and nitrogen so when we melt
those materials which it's easier to do
because they they have lower melting
points um we basically make magma or
lava of those materials so that's that's
their magma that's their lava so it just
depends where you are we just need to
center ourselves in the right world so
whatever happens basically you need to
heat the stuff so if you've got rock
with inside a planet which we do if you
delve down into our planet it's hard and
it's rocky um we need to melt that stuff
in order to make it rise as soon as you
make a liquid of of a solid thing then
it's more buoyant and it just wants to
naturally rise through that body so
that's generally what happens now the
other thing with magmas is that they
often contain a lot of gases
and these gases just want to escape so
they kind of over pressure this magma as
it rises up and that causes it to just
keep rising and keep rising and melting
its way through the crust until it gets
to the surface
and then basically what happens is those
gases want to just erupt out of that
lava very quickly and that's generally
what makes the explosion at the surface
if we see something you know like
mountain helens or somewhere that was
just that magma basically exploding as
it got to the surface and blowing that
mountain apart
as that pressure is released when you
get to that normally if so if the
explosion blows our mountain apart how
do we get the mountain in the first
place
so the mountain initially was built up
from very like continuous eruptions of
lava and ash and so we call these
stratovolcanoes
and so they generally build up quite
slowly over years and years and and then
you know trees grow on them and they
look just like a mountain and we don't
think they're scary and this is partly
why volcanoes are very dangerous
has a very nice shape oh it's beautiful
yeah and i've you know i loved with the
olympics coverage yes it was gorgeous
beautiful
image all the time and snow capped
mountain and i think it's the volcano
that looks most like a child's drawing
of a volcano yes exactly it doesn't even
look real right
yeah yeah it's beautiful and i think
that's why we we sort of forget as
humans because these are you know
volcanoes can erupt not very often but
they're still classed as active so 10
000 years is usually the time frame
where we say if it hasn't erupted for 10
000 years then it might be not active
any longer but the problem is we don't
as humans remember that kind of time
frame so people live close to volcanoes
for many different reasons um the that
the land around volcanoes is often very
fertile so it's really good to make
crops and everything and grow stuff and
also the land is cheap because it is
known not to be very safe really you
think
but people have to live in these places
location location location exactly and
they're beautiful so you know i would
quite like this has good schools it's
got good roads but you're on the side of
a volcano
as much vessels as you need
i we
we went on a trip to italy and visited
vesuvius you know famous for pompeii
and
no there's no lava there that i saw but
it was hot
we went near the caldera it's like oh my
gosh
yeah i was like whoa
and that obviously is very famous for
pompeo very famous
the ruins yeah yeah yeah of course of
course yeah there are vineyards on this
side of vesuvius that are thusly
identified on the label so if you want
to get it so taste a bit of ash
that's the thing about ash it's really
it's really really good for soil so you
know whilst uh a huge amount of it
coming down the mountain like pompeii um
you know is rather devastating um small
scatterings of ash quite often are
really great for soil and it has this
great ability that it can absorb water
into the soil so it acts as like a
fertilizer in the soil and and helps to
create these amazing crops
and irrigated very very interesting yeah
cool all right matt give me some more
yeah well so this is nicholas godlov and
along these lines nicholas is asking
should we be worried or afraid of the
super volcanoes of earth and what is the
most menacing volcano to you in our
solar system oh good one
okay uh so yeah super volcanoes that's a
great subject because we hear about i
think yellowstone is probably the most
famous one we hear about because it's
always you know in the media oh it's
going to erupt you know it's going to
erupt next year and it's going to
devastate everything but
right now like it's jew is how it's
always described
and it is always true you know but um
because we don't have a huge amount of
data of how often it's erupted but the
thing is with these super volcanoes is
if they do go it would be massively
devastating and they create caldera
eruptions so you don't really see
anything on the surface initially you
don't see a volcano like mount fuji um
what will happen is that the ground will
literally just explode and you'll end up
with this massive caldera left behind
and that has happened throughout history
um but the thing is with these but that
area still has good schools right it
still does
it's a great place to visit
it could blow up completely but before
that happens you get
things with super volcanoes whilst they
have the potential to do that and we
think there's a massive magma chamber
sort of under the surface that could be
bubbling away let's say and you know
potentially going to erupt you're a
geologist
why don't you know this
for sure why can't you
find oil why can't you thump the ground
and find where the magma chamber is that
might bust so we know that we can do the
seismic surveys we know sort of where
the ground is hotter and where there's
molten material but it doesn't mean it's
all going to erupt in one go it could be
that it has small eruptions and lets a
bit of steam and then has another one
and so they wouldn't be devastating and
therefore it lets off their steam and
then it's not going to erupt for you
know another million years so
they're almost never as bad as we think
they're going to be and if one is really
going to erupt then we're going to know
about it because we're studying them in
detail and we'd have a good idea if it
was going to do something okay that's
encouraging because otherwise to say oh
it might erupt in the next four thousand
years that's not helpful
and how about the other half of that
question
what was that i've already forgotten oh
that was what is the most menacing
volcano
to you in our solar system
menacing oh but i don't like to give the
menacing titles because even they're all
lovely but now we're saying
i guess it's going to be supposed to
feel for the volcano
they don't have feelings for you
they will melt you in an instant okay
vaporize you
i guess i wouldn't want to be sitting on
io because i think on io you're almost
certainly going to be captured by an
eruption somewhere and even if not
you'll have probably lava spattered on
you from one of its erupting volcanoes
um and you know its surface is just
incredibly hot and well so what about i
know it's not active but olympus mons on
mars is that the biggest volcanic
mountain in the whole solar system yeah
it's massive you know it's like three
times higher than mount everest it's
it's absolutely enormous but the thing
is it's not much different to hawaii so
um the volcanoes that we see you know uh
you know on mauna loa mauna kea it's a
very similar type of volcano and
actually they're not particularly scary
when it erupts like i think you know the
most recent big eruption was kind of
2018 people were able to out walk the
the lava most of the time you know yes
it was devastating it kind of you know
covered houses and land but
you could out walk it so it's not
this i never heard that sentence before
let's uh matt let's out walk the lava
morning constitutional away from the
burning rocks
[Laughter]
very cool so matt let's slip in one more
question before we take our second break
all right well i'm going to given that
we're talking about olympus mons there
are two questions two different people
have written in questions that include
that so camera cameron bishop asks
uh what properties determine the size of
a volcano and how did these properties
allow olympus mons to get so big could
such a volcano form here on earth
and jared sauber says if olympus mons
was able to grow so large due to mars
weak gravity why don't we see even
larger volcanoes on other active bodies
such as some of the larger moons
yeah brilliant so yeah and that second
question's got it exactly right so mars
is about half the size of earth so it
has less gravity so it means that things
can simply just grow bigger so if we
took an
olympus modern sized volcano or mountain
and put it on earth it would basically
collapse under its own weight because it
would just be too heavy um and so it
just it couldn't form here it would
literally just wouldn't be able to get
that big um the other way that uh mars
has been able to grow such a large
volcano is because it doesn't have plate
tectonics now i'm hoping most of the
listeners are going to know what plate
tectonics is it's a thing that's very uh
unique to earth we think and it's where
the outside of our um crust of our
planet is basically broken into pieces
which move around in relation to each
other and they can kind of knock into
each other or they create earthquakes
when they slide past one another um and
they are what creates many of our
volcanoes but and by the way just to be
clear
y'all
only fully embraced that
within the last 60 years right yeah it's
not a forever ago thing
yeah it was literally i think it's the
1960s wasn't it yeah yeah so 60 years
suggested that it was a thing and people
were like no the man's crazy you know he
did yeah no i think the suggestion
predates that but before the evidence
really
gathered
i didn't know that and i also really
didn't know that earth was the only
body that we know of that has this i
thought it was a fairly universal thing
across no
so that's how we get lots of our
volcanoes but the other type of albican
is luckily come from mantle plumes and
this is the type again hawaii is the
classic example um this is a big chimney
of hot rock that rises from the interior
of the earth possibly as deep as the
core and it comes all the way up through
the planet and then erupts molten lava
at the surface and these are very
long-lived features on our planet now if
you just imagine a this chimney of rock
in the planet and these plates are
moving over the top of that so what we
have what happens at hawaii is we get
this chain of volcanoes this you know
chimney of rock keeps erupting and the
plate moves over it and we get volcanoes
you know going along in a linear chain
so the most recent ones are mounted
lower of hair now in mars we've got
exactly the same thing yeah so this is
an archipelago right isn't that what an
archipelago yeah exactly yeah and and
many of the caribbean islands are so
what you're saying is it's not a
continuous busting through of the of the
plate it busts through and then it stays
calm for a while and over that period
this plate shift and it's okay time to
bust through again but there you go and
absolutely completely
but that's that's fascinating to me
because i in my head like these sort of
chains of volcanoes i assume they were
like all along a fault line or something
like that but you're saying it's it's
almost more like a sort of
like a factory line where there's
they're moving along like the earth is
moving along on a conveyor belt and
every so often it punches a hole through
it and it goes on a bit more and
precisely and so if you go to honolulu
and people like oh it's volcanic could
it erupt no you can't because it's
nowhere near that plume now um so that
is almost certainly not going to happen
but that other island that's the one
yeah that's the one we need to worry
about with the molten lava crater at the
top yeah and also i think i'm right in
that the big island in hawaii
would not be sustainable were that fully
on land
that the buoyancy of rock and water
allows that to build as high as it did
through from the bottom of the ocean
through the ocean surface and then above
the ocean surface because it doesn't
weigh as much simply because it's half
of it is sitting in water is that yeah
exactly yeah because i think people
forget with those islands that you know
what we see above is not even half of it
and in the middle of the freaking
pacific ocean right yeah where it goes
we gotta take another quick break
another quick break and when we come
back matt you got more questions for
natalie starkey our geologist turned
astro person bookkeeper on star talk
we're back star talk
neil degrasse tyson here matt where can
we find you on social media
uh you can find me uh matt kirschen on
the various things and probably science
is my podcast
all the podcast platforms hey wherever
podcasts are sold near you yes okay
yeah i'll get your local bookshop for uh
my podcast yeah there you go and uh
natalie where can we find you on social
media and i'm at starkey stardust on
yeah all the platforms and uh
[ __ ] stardust s-t-a-r-k-e-y
yeah starkey stardust i love it yeah
yeah yeah so um i think i think we had
to take a break before you completed the
answer to why olympus mons is so big on
mars so
so we we learned that um
the hawaiian
chain of islands they're all volcanic
and that's just magma punching through
in a new spot as the as the plate
tectonics take it by so mars i think
doesn't have plate tectonics so exactly
we don't think it does we haven't got
any evidence for it there now obviously
it's not an active planet today so we
know it's not happening today trying to
work out whether it happened in the past
we just don't have any evidence for it
so we don't think it did so we we call
it a stagnant lid planet basically just
one big crust and it didn't move so what
happens there is if you've got one of
these mantle plumes coming up from the
interior of the planet onto the surface
that plate isn't moving anywhere it's
just going to carry on erupting for
millions of years through the same hole
through the city the same whole even
billion years or more um so yeah it just
grows larger and larger and larger in
one place and that's exactly what
happened with the olympus mons all right
cool
cool which is the largest volcanic
mountain in the solar system i think
it's the largest mountain isn't it yeah
yeah yeah okay good good all right matt
keep them coming okay well this is a
question chester lipschitz has sent in
that uh touches on both of your areas of
expertise
do today's volcanic
activities have much of an uh have much
of any impact on the cooling down and
gradual solidifying of the core
if so how long would it take would we
lose our ability to maintain a stable
magnetosphere and atmosphere before we
even have to worry about the problems
the sun is going to give us in a few
billion years oh wow what an apocalyptic
did he get any sleep at night
so i think he's basically then asking
like as as heat is coming out through
these volcanoes is it cooling down the
inside of the earth and is it doing it
at such a rate that it's going to start
changing how the earth is and let me
simplify that question to natalie why is
earth still hot yeah no that's exactly
it so the volcanoes are basically just a
manifestation of a planet cooling itself
down so it has all this internal heat
and it needs to go somewhere and
volcanoes let that heat escape into
space you know which means we are
cooling down we we are cooling down so
but luckily we have plenty of heat so
we've got two main two types of heat in
in most of the planets will be
the the heat that was left over from the
formation of the planet so that when the
planets formed it was all a bit chaotic
and
things were colliding with each other
and basically kinetic energy of two
objects colliding into each other turns
into heat energy and so it gets trapped
within the cores of most of the planets
so all the moons in fact so we've got a
lot of heat from four and a half billion
years ago and it's been trapped in ever
since um outside of the core we've got a
mantle which is made up of silicate
rocks so these are kind of the basalts
and stuff we were talking about that's a
really good insulator so it keeps that
it's kept that heat inside the planet
the larger you are the more heat you can
retain now the other way that would
create heat is actually continuous
process and it's it's nuclear heat so
we've actually got radioactive decay
going on within our planet basically
atoms that are unstable
decay to more stable atoms and they
release heat during this process because
they release little atoms that then
collide with other things inside the
planet and create heat now it sounds
like it wouldn't be very uh an important
process but actually there's so much
decay going on in the planet that we're
creating about half our current day heat
from that process so why isn't mars also
creating heat
so it is but it's cooled down a lot more
now because it started off smaller so it
never had as much heat to start with and
then because its mantle is smaller and
it's crossed where it has all these heat
producing elements it then has just lost
that heat okay so we have volcanoes and
and venus stars volcanoes
yeah venus is probably a similar
temperature inside we talk about the
surface temperature of the planets it
almost doesn't really relate to what's
going on inside so mercury being right
next to the sun can even had have ice on
its surface and its insides are still
molten another side of that question was
if it does cool down we might lose our
magnetic field
because you the way you drive a magnetic
field by the movement
of
conducting materials
right and when you move charges
you you
within a field you generate
within an electric field you can
generate a magnetic field and so
we rely on a molten
inner region of iron
sulfur conducting material to generate a
magnetic field which shields us from
certain forms of uh the solar wind that
could then strip our our our atmosphere
of of uh very um
of molecules that we care about okay
including the water molecule right so
so
uh did i characterize that accurately
there yeah perfect see our outer core is
actually molten and our inner core is
solid so it's that molten iron rotating
around inside the planet that keeps our
magnetic field alive and without it we
wouldn't be here because life we just
would be bombarded with radiation so
that's what or we'd be living just under
water we'd maybe be living under water
because you would be if you had an ice
cover like you find at europa which is
obviously sitting next to jupiter which
has this horrible magnetic field if your
life and it could be like
if you're live
otherwise it's just fine if you're a
rock would you care
i mean if you're a robot then you might
be in trouble as well so that's worth
considering yeah and that's we do have
to really protect um space equipment
that we send out there
from radiation in space because you know
you know this can damage uh cameras very
easily so yeah it's something we have to
worry about but mars if we go back to
mars it was it did have a molten
interior and then it it no longer does
so it's lost its magnetic fields so this
is why we talk about life might have
been there in the past because it had
all the right conditions but but it also
means terraforming mars might have
bigger challenges than we think yeah
because you might be able to turn it
into earth but to sustain it
requires the rest of this shielding to
happen yeah we have to live in caves and
i think it would be miserable but you
know maybe people want to go and do that
but we need to live underground to
protect ourselves using the rock to
basically shield us from the radiation
okay so my favorite thing about the show
is i can make a stupid joke about robots
in terms of accident and he says
something smart
it was a very insightful point man thank
you that's what i was going for uh i
appreciate that two scientists there
thank you for okay keep them coming what
else you have in front well this is also
um
uh this is this is also touching on
neil's expertise as well because uh
marcus gustafson says from sweden asks
can asteroids develop volcanoes and
would that make its orbit unpredictable
because of the thrust it would generate
oh cool
that's very cool and yes yes yes it can
so we've actually discovered that um
some of this the asteroids like uh some
of the series and actually that's got
ice volcanoes on it um and there's a
mission called psyche which is a nasa
mission i think i don't know when it's
launching not not long now it's going to
this asteroid called psyche 16. and they
think it had iron volcanoes on it
potentially um way in way in the past um
now whether those volcanoes just to be
clear and i don't want to be pedantic or
anything but ceres
got upgraded in its designation in the
soul this is true unlike pluto yeah so
pluto got downgraded from planet syria
got upgraded from asteroids and they're
both dwarf planets now so so you i don't
i will not accept you to cite ceres as a
place for asteroidal volcanoes it's in
the asteroid belt i'm going to call it
an asteroid it's a dwarf gun and an
asteroid
okay i guess since location does matter
to geologists because magma outside of a
volcano is called lava
that's how you roll
so also of course comets as they come
near and far from the sun plumes will
develop that do alter their their
trajectories right yeah and so
um with comets
predicting their orbits are is a highly
um risky but not risky it's highly
uncertain activity simply because you
don't know where the next plume is going
to come out that will then have the
comet recoil and give you a different
kind of orbit than you were expecting
yeah and when they go near the sun they
can explode or pieces can come off and
then obviously they're a different size
and shape to what they've done before
they went around the sun
or disintegrate or get eaten by the sun
entirely yeah yeah yeah
okay matt wait time for a few more yeah
well this is obviously the counterpart
to this question from and i hope i'm
getting your name close to correct uh
zenkuti bence
asks
can can an eruption have such power to
send rocks to space
if a giant eruption happened in
yellowstone would it send rocks to space
uh which would then fall back down on
earth is the second part of that
question and that that question comes
from hungary
yeah so i guess once you're in space
you're in space you're not going to
probably come back very easy but that
wouldn't really happen on our planet
because we've got so much gravity that i
just don't think we could have a strong
enough powerful enough eruption that you
could get out into space but obviously
in other places we know that enceladus
its plumes you know go 200 kilometers
high and and make the e-ring of saturn
to sure enough that is you know
eruptions going into space but i may be
wrong but i don't i don't think that
could happen on earth but sure enough
like our eruptions do go very high into
the stratosphere quite often with these
plinion style eruptions which is what
happened at um vesuvius and the material
then the ash and the gases kind of
encircle the planet but within you know
our atmosphere and uh and can block out
the sun for weeks and months to come and
that can create lots of kind of
long-term damage to the planet in a way
yeah excellent and i would add that even
if it did eject from the volcano at
escape velocity the atmosphere is going
to tamp that down
and it will not likely ever escape the
earth because it won't maintain that
velocity uh as it ascends
or maintain the velocity necessary to
continue to escape the earth but there's
more than one sci-fi film where we have
astronauts on on on comet surfaces and
on
asteroidal surfaces where
it rotates into view of the sun there's
a plume that busts forth
and
people hardware is get kicked completely
off the asteroid never to return
yeah and that is something they worry
about with comet missions with the
rosetta mission they landed on that
comet and they had to choose somewhere
that didn't look very active didn't have
you know an active plume coming out
because you know they were genuinely
worried that that spacecraft you know
little lander would get shot off the
surface and be lost into space forever
so it is quite a worry
yeah yeah
that'd be a cool uh a cool video though
yeah
like r2 you know getting kicked out of
the thing i guess in the cipher world if
you're thinking about it if you do have
an ability to predict where these plumes
are going to come from that's a possible
launching site you can say well by using
that as a
very good match it's a trampoline oh my
gosh so that would have to be a
desperate situation where oh we're out
of fuel how are we ever going to get
back wait a minute there's a crack here
let's do that and then then that saves
them that reminds me there was a movie
called marooned
where
it's back in the 60s
before we landed on the moon and there's
some astronauts in space and something
goes wrong and they have to be rescued
but a hurricane was coming through
florida and over cape canaveral so they
couldn't launch a rescue mission and
then someone figures out wait a minute
the eye of the hurricane is going to go
over cape canaveral
so they
they connected the countdown to the this
i was very young so i didn't know
hurricanes had eyes i didn't know any or
that it's beautiful in the middle of a
hurricane i didn't know any of this or
that heart that florida was hurricane
prone right and so they actually
launched into see this launch coming out
from the center it was beautiful it's a
beautiful
beautiful uh concept i'm not sure how
exactly they wheel the rocket out
through the hurricane waiting
if i know anything about rocket
launchers they're quite easily postponed
it doesn't take much
it doesn't take much for them to say
like this isn't safe we need to wait
another couple of days yeah but it was
cool it was a cool move though yeah yeah
okay time for a couple more questions
maybe one more questions one more time
for one more question matt okay well i
like i like this one because there's
been some other questions that i think
we've we've covered anyway just through
question things that have come up
naturally so uh boris meganic i again
i'm magenic i hope i'm getting your name
close says okay here's a silly and
possible possibly ignorant one i say
it's not ignorant i i'm the one who
asked the ignorant questions here please
stay in your lane
there's only one room for one ignorant
person on this show uh boris is it
possible that a regular mountain can
become a volcano or a hunt or are a
hundred percent of volcanic mountain
shapes and mass created by the first
eruption itself
yeah yeah so once you if you've just got
a normal mountain and that is created
through normal mountain processes which
is usually from plate tectonics so
you've got two plates colliding and
nothing gets melted they just kind of
crumple up against each other um because
they're being forced together you know a
few centimeters per year that's how we
get the himalayas so those mountains and
you know mount everest are not volcanic
they never will be um they're just
getting taller and taller every year um
because you know those plates are
crushing together and pushing up crust
above the surface so no we sorry no no
no big mountains will become so the
subcontinent no it didn't get the memo
that like russia is in the way right
yeah
it's like i'm still moving i'm still
gone
so natalie i'm wondering in the vein of
that question could we actually
take a spot on earth and drill to where
the the molten rock is and sort of force
a volcano to to erupt
where we choose it to i guess if we knew
the magma was there that would
technically not technically be possible
because that would be hot you're a
geologist you know where this stuff is
drilling into hot stuff is never going
to be easy because everything's going to
melt anyway but like if we knew there
was a magma chamber there we probably
know a volcano is there anyway like
you're not gonna just get a magma
chamber without a volcano but actually
what we do do a lot is kind of use the
heat that's given out by these magmas
sitting below the crust to generate
electricity so in iceland they do this a
lot iceland is obviously all volcanic it
sits on the mid-ocean region it's also
got a mantle plume there so it's a
massively volcanic place and they film
cosm many scenes and cosmos there
because it's because you have it looks
like they're you you aim the camera this
way it's like
earth is forming you aim it here it's
like there are these plumes where's the
dinosaur you know
we had all manner of earth formation
scenarios all without any kind of set
design it was all it was already there
and the great thing is that there's so
much heat just literally just under the
crust there that they they just generate
all their electricity for free because
they can use geothermal energy so they
pump down water into the crust it gets
heated up and gets shot back up and they
could use that too but by the way as i
learned that was only in recent decades
until
the 90s i think they were still using
fossil fuels and somebody said what the
hell are you doing you know this hates
yeah
i i think they actually send heat on
their roads i was gonna say because it
is cold a lot of yeah yeah they send
heat on the roads and it melts all the
ice so then yeah so they don't yeah
they'd have to grip the road so yeah i
found out recently that iceland has the
highest electricity use per capita of
any country in the world by quite some
way which makes them sound like they're
not green but it's the opposite because
they do everything with basically
fossil fuel free electricity
yeah and if you and and if you're just
tapping heat out you leave the lights on
okay
and then they you can you can have all
these saunas everywhere and hot swimming
pools and everything so they have loads
of swimming pools just because they can
heat them really easily and all outdoor
pools and you know when it's really cold
and you're like oh that's going to be
horrible but it's great because right
right
uh so let me uh just to end with can i
reverse that question and
um
if
i heard that the name of a of a
fraternity uh i mean it was a it was a
joke name it's called i tap a keg right
okay so
okay can we can there be a volcano that
we think is going to erupt
and then can we tap it off the side and
have it kind of like a release
of the pressure
to delay what might be a larger
singular eruption of the cone
no i think the problem is we just still
don't know enough about volcanoes to be
able to predict their behavior damn
natalie i thought
[Music]
but basically with a lot of volcanoes
like there's the montserrat in the
caribbean as a classic example it's this
volcanic dome which sits above the
surface but it's really unstable so you
know even a lot of rainfall can
destabilize the slopes of that volcano
because it's just not very well
consolidated and mashed together and
that can destabilize the magma chamber
underneath and then create a massive
eruption so basically you're taking off
kind of the lid of the pressure cooker a
little bit you're just releasing a bit
of pressure and then it can then erupt
really badly so we wouldn't want to
meddle i think we have to leave nature
to do its thing and the best way for us
to get away is just to move people away
that's so defeatist wait till your kids
become geologists
that's so old-fashioned
yeah we just tap this energy here we run
the energy needs of the town we get the
volcano will never erupt and we gotta
we're good wait till the next generation
they'll figure it out but there is one
possible i don't know if you have time
but just to squeeze in one extra
question from moses conrad norman who
asks can you have a planet that is
entirely volcanoes and volcanic activity
yeah i guess io is the closest one to
that and it's almost like our planet
four billion years ago so our planet
four billion years ago was almost
certainly covered in volcanoes and most
of the surface was just very hot
probably molten um and volcanoes were
going off all over the place uh so that
is what's happening at i o still it's
not quite that bad but it is very very
active um so yeah like it definitely
it's just it's got again it's got that
kind of tidal energy inside because it's
right next to jupiter this massive
planet so it's being squashed and
squeezed friction is happening inside
and it's creating heat and that's just a
continuous process so let me just put
this to bed right here so if in in the
old days we would well maybe even in
modern times we would see drawings of
dinosaurs
and there was always a volcano on the
horizon as though
dinosaurs which was 100 million years
ago
somehow earth was covered with volcanoes
100 million years ago but that's like
yesterday compared to the geologic time
scale so they they're that's all wrong i
guess isn't that correct yeah i mean
yeah there were volcanoes obviously at
the time but not like that kind of era
that we see where they're just you know
it's all volcanic right right it's not
every direction you look there's a lot
of dynamics
and plants don't like volcanoes very
much so
but there are dinosaurs on io
well that's not what we said man we
haven't seen them yet
you heard it here
all right we got to call it quits there
natalie's always great to have you and
again thanks for being the author of our
current space show with the hayden
planetarium worlds beyond earth matt
will find you on probably science still
waiting for my next invitation to appear
as a guest the second the second you
have anything you want to come on and
talk about uh if you your next book
or just just a whim you are the door is
wide open all right very pleased to hear
hear that
that invitation get extorted from you
very much the other way around
i'm neil degrasse tyson director of that
planetarium where natalie starkey
wrote the latest space show as always
for star talk i bid you to keep
[Music]
you